[Musica]
No vabbè non le camere ci hanno visto
abbiamo attivato il sistema di sicurezza
Ciao verde si chiameranno blu e Green
Che fantastica è come come Firenze
Benvenuto
con gli alieni come potete vedere qua si
vede già un alieno gigante che vuole
stritolarci in modo che come sempre
Mettetevi comodi prendete da mangiare
qualcosa da bere mi piace iniziamo
subito
Wow Iniziamo bene allora dove sei tu
Erick
Cos'è questo Indiana Jones
Siamo bloccati dobbiamo trovare un modo
per tornare a casa Ok
fai attenzione quando attraversi la
strada
[Musica]
Ricordati di raccogliere tutti i Block
Stoker e buona fortuna Ok ne dobbiamo
raccogliere 25 figo via Ok iniziamo ad
attraversare senza farsi
schiaccicare ok È stato abbastanza
facile fin qui quindi è questa l'area 51
Dobbiamo ancora entrare nella
recitazione
[Musica]
non siamo neanche ancora entrati Sono
scivolato Mi sa insomma vediamo che dice
indiana sali sul palo dell'illuminazione
per arrivare dall'altra parte Scusa non
potrebbe cioè magari un po' pericoloso
salire lì la sopra o acquista il tappeto
per attraversare più facilmente
però è pericoloso passare qui Ok Ah ecco
perché vedi io sono caduto prima
[Musica]
però almeno almeno c'è l'acqua sotto
vedi Quindi non dovrebbe essere così un
impatto Beh ti sei sfracellata lo stesso
ruba la carta di accesso alla Guardia
mentre dorme
e poi apri il cancello No ancora no Devo
rubare la chiave
[Musica]
e poi raggiungi l'ingresso li troveremo
un razzo che ci porterà a casa
Wow
che figata Ok allora come faccio a
rubarlo Aspetta però perché c'è
l'ingresso devo rubare la carta senza
svegliarlo
presa non si è svegliato e dai dai
Prendi prendi questa parte devi passare
sulla cosa blu Ah ok perfetto
siamo entrato l'aria 51 che è proibito
nessuno sa che cosa ci stia dentro cosa
c'è scritto attenzione Non si può
passare non si possono fare fotografie
Top Secret credo che mi hanno detto Mi
hanno già preso
No vabbè vabbè ho visto
mi hanno fatto una foto abbiamo attivato
il sistema di sicurezza e quindi e
quindi ci sono i laser con le fiamme Oh
no sarebbe stato molto più semplice se
non ci avessero visto
Beh ovviamente entriamo in un luogo di
sicurezza possibile così grande quindi
ci sono le camere Guarda gli alieni Che
carini eh Ciao Bruno verde si
chiameranno blu e Green Che fantastica è
come come prezzo
l'originalità di Vitale
Ma che cavolo è successo Io mi sono
sfracellators cioè Iper mortali
quando passano salti e vai dentro
Perfetto riprovo aspetto qui quando
passa il laser Uh vado avanti
vai vai adesso no aspetta eh Ti devi
sbrigare quando passa dietro
Perfetto Ok vai vai vai vai vai
è successo Vabbè raccogli la chiave
Allora dobbiamo prendere questa chiave
per aprire la bocca
in che senso
eh ah ah sono morti tutti Allora questi
laser sono un po' particolari bisogna
essere mmm mmm no vabbè ma sono
difficilissimi ma soprattutto perché
trasformano il mio personaggio così Ciao
io sono passato Ciao ciao ciao ciao
è difficilissimo perché io sono troppo
forte Uh ho preso il mio primo robot
gigante rosso non è un robot
Allora spiegami come hai fatto
Ho superato il primo è già un Progresso
li devo rifare anch'io
quel blocchetto
Allora qua ci vuole la chiave va avevamo
preso la chiave prima o no no no l'ho
fatto vedere dove sono ritornato
indietro
allora non so come fare
Eh sì Non ci credo Devo rifare da capo
questa parte di laser ma sono veramente
Crudeli Chi ha fatto queste Escape Ma tu
hai capito come si fa a saltare qui mi
sono già sfracellato un paio di volte
non lo so proviamo Ok come hai fatto
doppio salto
uh uh uh
[Musica]
Evviva sta andando benissimo per ora ma
Wow Questa è la famosa Area 51
occhio tipo un alieno acquatico
Wow e ci sono i pesci d'acqua i serpenti
d'acqua eh Le lumache d'acqua e anche un
occhio d'acqua
non pensare di essere così tanto in
vantaggio eh
per caso sì ma ora ti sfracellerai tanto
Oggi abbiamo due fiorellini gialli voto
da 1 a 10 scrivete nei commenti e avete
lasciato mi piace cliccate mi piace qua
sotto piano Io odio il laser Li odio
come l'ho detto tutti e due eh
OK riproviamo
eh Alien Alien Come si può chiamare un
elenco solo con un occhio ai
prendi Vitale mi voglio godere tutte le
volte che la vita si sfracella sono qui
su in alto in alto ciao ciao ciao
Adesso ti raggiungo piano piano ok
almeno posso salvare qua e ora
raggiungiamo Vitale superiamolo io vado
a fare merenda Ciao a tutti
Qual è l'area 51 Uh
aspetta ah ah uno due Oh bravo Ci sei
quasi manca poco Guarda io sono qui Ciao
ciao
qua che dobbiamo fare allora c'è questa
porta che
seguiamo Brava brava Giusto
meglio seguirlo che scappare
ciao e io sono in vantaggio solo perché
mi hai aspettato
Pensavo che eri tu che tirisfracellata
no sono pure caduto Eccolo
ce la farà Ciao ciao
sì andiamo
Andiamo
le frecce Che bello quando vieni la
Brindisi ci sono le frecce non si si
perde Oppure era una trappola Forse era
una trappola
ce l'abbiamo fatta ad arrivare alla
stanza dello spazio porto Premi il
bottone per aprire la porta
il missile Cioè è rifatto il razzo per
tornare a casa
Ok Wow via ma in tutto ciò abbiamo preso
solo uno su 25
Come abbiamo fatto a prendere solo due
no ho bruciato il tiro Comunque sono
troppo esagerati c'è ho capito che che
vuoi far morire il personaggio ma non lo
devi pure fare brutto brutto
diventare tutto rosso Allora ho superato
ho aperto la porta davvero Ma la porta è
chiusa
la devi aprire tu mi dispiace ciao ciao
Aspettami devo scappare senza di me Dai
vai a premere col pulsante Ok ora arriva
qua
sei appena entrata
dobbiamo andare beh qua ma il pavimento
è un po' rotto no non è il pavimento
rotto questo è tipo liquido di alieno
appena trascritto
Certo che è un po' strana questa area 51
il razzo
ci dovrebbe essere un cosetto da
prendere
è un robot da prendere qui come si
chiamava l'hai visto Eccomi sono
arrivato
sul razzo Vediamo se esplode forse va
tutto bene
questo razzo in viaggio questo razzo in
viaggio verso
la luna andare verso la terra non verso
la luna No vabbè ora che facciamo Siamo
sulla luna Wow che figo possiamo saltare
Uh Zero gravita Ah ah ah
figo andiamo Ma ci possono spedire sulla
terra con un altro razzo Beh penso che
alla fine lo troveremo l'altro raggio e
ci spediranno Che figo saltare così in
tutta la vita Wow
hai visto sfracellato però chiama chi
arriva prima alla stazione spaziale Uh
Qua c'è una freccia Devo prendere
qualcosa uh mi sembra un drink Grazie
L'hai preso il pulsante rosso qui No che
pulsanti
ah ah ok Ho bevuto il mio drink
rafforzante Mi sono trasformata in super
sayan adesso
piano piano piano piano piano e via
fighissimo poter volare
e adesso Ah devo riuscire arrivare là in
corsa e via
spaventatissimo ho trovato un robot eh
attento perché è molto facile cadere lì
eh Non c'è problema no ce l'hai fatta tu
perché io sono capace
[Risate]
Wow Aspetta sto salvando
se ho salvato così adesso non dovrò
ricominciare tutto da capo ogni volta Eh
sì devo riuscire anche io prendiamo bene
via uh uh uh
ah questa volta non mi freghi l'una e no
devi prendere più risorse
Ok brava brava
ti manca poco ti manca poco
[Musica]
Brava Brava ok Qua è difficile vai vai
vai vai vai vai va bene così
ok
È lì sì devi fare un po' di ricotta al
salto Brava brava brava
Brava Ecco il castello laggiù Ci siamo
quasi dobbiamo stare attenti qui Allah
Sì ma non abbiamo più la super velocità
Ok dai però coi salti abbastanza
semplice
sono in vantaggio c'è un altro c'è un
altro pulsante qui No io non rischio di
cadere giù sopra un robot Io l'ho preso
sono in vantaggio
credo che quelli davanti a noi sono
saranno molto difficili da attraversare
Sì sono minuscoli No dai Ce la possiamo
fare questa è la parte più difficile
bisogna prendere bene la mira
Wow dai Pensavo fosse più difficile ce
l'abbiamo fatta forza mi sono anche in
vantaggio sono proprio davanti
al castello Ehi Che cosa è successo
no
uh uh e adesso ho salvato
ok Il primo l'ho passato il secondo però
devi aspettare via via via via via via
via via No io mi sa che aspetto ancora
un attimino
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
specificato proprio lì sotto il video
veloce Ok guarda ci siamo Oh finalmente
la visuale normale
a casa aiuto
è uno di questi qua Allora aspetta che
passi Eh corri corri corri corri corri
sotto terra No va bene Poco aspettiamo
che torni quando torna indietro noi
usciamo
se lo troviamo capiamo da qui
No un piccolo cieco siamo chiusi in una
prigione spaziale
dalla prigione Ehi ti sto tirando fuori
Grazie cosa è successo un alieno è
scappato dalla sezione 4 e dobbiamo
uscire da qui Wow
Guarda il gabinetto oppure è stato
vitale nel frattempo che stavamo
aspettando No no non sono stato io a
fare quelle cose eh verdi fumose
anche a me l'ha preso allora c'erano dei
laser non ce ne siamo accorti ma dove
bisogna passare allora vediamo questa
parte qua gialla
però quando non ci sono i laser semplice
No
ok salta quando arriva il laser salta Sì
certo mi ha appena
frittola Ok Qua possiamo salvare bene
questo che ci ha aiutato a scappare ci
poteva spiegare che ci sono dei laser
che ci friggono
alcune porte delle prigioni sono aperte
e ci sono i robot grossi
andiamo a prenderli
Ecco perché non vado a prenderli
odio i laser Li odio Ah forse è soltanto
qua sopra al tavolo perché può saltare
meglio il laser E comunque mi ha preso
di nuovo il laser non ti conviene andare
a prendere quei robot
Ma insomma non ho toccato niente dai
l'ultimo l'ultimo
Brava
allora attiviamo il pulsante qui che
cosa è successo Non lo so cosa succede
con il pulsante e però l'hai tolto
mettere tutto insieme
e adesso lo tocca pure io così di
sforacelli ah ah ah comunque non ho
fatto niente
primi due bottoni su ogni lato
e il teletrasporto si aprirà
dobbiamo giocare di squadra Quindi
ognuno di noi deve vederli per forza e
come fanno quelli che giocano da soli
Poverino
entrambi Ci sono dei robot
mi sto prendendo di questi pulsanti
Rossi
Allora era facile Saltare
su dei Delle specie di mattonelle Anche
io oh io mi sto teletrasportando Ciao
io no Ah perché devi premere l'altro
bottone pensavo che basta solo premevi
tu
Wow
dove sei finito e devo dire che non sono
finito sulla terra sono finito ancora su
un'altra su un'altra parte della
navicella spaziale qui eh Sei arrivato
anche tu Vediamo Sì mi state
letteralmente trasportando Ciao Ciao
Anita
dove siamo eh C'è un alieno qui forse
siamo tornati all'inizio che è scappato
hanno detto che c'è un alieno che è
scappato dall'area 4 Ah ma forse ci
mangi mi sono sfracellato Sì vabbè che
succede
sta andando sulla terra
ci sta portando con lui sì che però
torneremo torneremo alla terra
viaggeremo attraverso il suo stomaco
o no ma quella lì mangiati dall'aniello
ma è caduto sulla terra Ora possiamo
uscire dal suo stomaco e correre al
sicuro
verde che usciva Dal suo sedere
3 No no Quante preferite No non è giusto
però Certo che questa lì è uno dei denti
molto umani Infatti sono le gengive
molto umane Vabbè ok Vediamo com'è fatto
un alieno c'ha dei tubi Rosati
all'interno saranno delle vene no
srogellato E poi ha delle scale
rosa e viola
all'interno del corpo e qua ha il cuore
umano siamo molto vicini a quella zona
lì mi sa no
mmm
mmm sono stata sciolta dagli acidi dello
stomaco
ok No vabbè basta Ma come è possibile
giocare
sempre
ce l'hai fatta No sono finita da
un'altra parte che succede Forse perché
sei passata attraverso quel
oh no
adesso sono imprigionata qua viene a
salvarmi ma forse perché sei passato in
uno di questi raggi luminosi
Non lo so che cosa è successo prova ad
azzerare il personaggio Ok ragazzi mi ha
aiutato Vitale a superare questa parte
non avete idea di quante volte mi sono
sfracellata Andiamo andiamo Non vedo
l'ora di salvare Sì subito subito Evviva
Ok allora qui ci abbiamo dei laser e del
Beh beh beh eh eh sono le costole ma eh
Forse ha mangiato un essere umano
Vitale
Allora forse non ne vale la pena andare
a prendere quei mattoncini Rossi Eh l'ho
preso subito Ok
sono riuscita a salire qua senza
scrutellarmi
E ora dove dobbiamo andare devi salire
sulle costole vai Ci siamo Vai forza
e ora che sarà una parte preferita
in basso
ma c'è un villaggio
aspetta siamo fuori dov'è il peggio No
non mi dire neanche al peggio
che dice lui eh Sì siamo arrivati al
nostro nascondiglio nascondiglio perché
perché perché perché nascondino passa
sui pad per giocare ai giochi più
divertenti
non abbiamo preso tutti i token Ah ecco
perché
usa questo teletrasporto per
ricominciare e trovarli No non mi dire
che non mi dà il badge perché non ho
preso due cose mancano io ne ho 14 di
25-18 di 25 mi ha preso qualcuno in più
non è giusto che non ci dà il Batch
perché non abbiamo preso i token uh ah
Però al di là di quello è stato
divertente questo Escape Room lasciate
quel mi piace E ora vi lasciamo Qua
quattro Casellina puoi cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite eh Buona visione
Ciao